[Music]
three two one action
what about top flow record we will be
talking about what today we're talking
about a hat on a team and Tim and Casey
who is not here but he should be where
do you how do you have a money or not
wait catch us up catch us up okay yeah
before we get into it I but those of you
guys who weren't here
there was another off the record in
which from a few weeks ago where Casey
Tim and a Dean they've been trying to
write a feature film and I think Casey
and Adam already had words like a pact
that are supposed to write one for the
yeah three months to write one
yeah and they didn't write that so now
Tim's like wow I've been trying to write
one too so they're like well let's give
each other two weeks and if we don't do
it we gotta eat this hot sauce in two
weeks and today is the two weeks and
where do you guys that well look first
of all I was trying to do it in a month
and then I don't know where you came up
with - the - I said 48 hours off camera
and we're having fun
this was like a a really deep emotional
so it wouldn't turn into entertainment
for others yes now it's all just content
for these guys there's a friendship
trying to help you out try to help you
achieve your goals yeah yeah
well yeah what are your real friends and
Joe negotiated up to two weeks for you
guys no Bart had it be a 48-hour thought
process I know the longer you give
yourself to do something right like I'm
like if what's harder starving yourself
for a day or really trying to stick to a
diet for six months disclaim
rediscoveries you never crashed I don't
crash they're trying to do something it
is easier to do a burst in a short
amount of time and so I was like and
I've written a couple scripts of Steve
already and every time we do it it's we
knock everything out but they were their
[ __ ] joke
you're in one [ __ ] I know you fun
and you're great in it like a skinny
thank you
and so happy complements all I know that
it works if you if you clear your
schedule and you compact it and you do
it in a short amount of time so I'm like
you need 48 hours and that's it and then
I think they wanted it longer and I'm
like no no no it's gotta be so be some
and it's somewhere the middle two weeks
but we do have an authority here who's
written over 14 scripts what do you
think should it be longer should be
shorter doesn't - it's not about getting
it completed in two weeks and like all
drafts it's about just getting it
[ __ ] like written so you have a first
draft first drafts can be horrible like
it's okay that's what that's why I was
[ __ ] up - because I was like let me
just write it let me just do this [ __ ]
like who cares if it's good or not but
the fact is my first one I've ever
written
I was really like I want this [ __ ] to be
good you know because I was I was doing
decently but there was a lot of things
excuses wise that came up this week but
when I was writing it I actually was
enjoying it I felt like it was going
really good I definitely needed more
time but then when I was texting them
and they were like oh like it's not that
like they're not gonna probably finish
for me I kind of was like ireland's no
matter what if we said if one of us has
a fish we all have to do the punishment
so I was like I don't want to rush it
and Ross we have to do the punishment so
you held each other down you let those
people held you down instead of pulling
them up it's sad to let that point it's
true it's true did you get 15 how far -
Casey get 10 also all in the same level
yeah amazing
that was Ryan bro norris group project
I'll fail I first of all I hate good
projects I said that for the beginning
of a hate group projects but I was
really trying to map this [ __ ] out like
I was really planning on doing it
because I was like all right let's say
this shit's like 80 to 100 pages I got
like a week and a half left [ __ ] save
the cat kind of breaks down how many
pages you should dedicate to each like
section of it I was like cool yeah I can
do like eight pages a day and so let me
go first then but then I would jack off
and I would fall asleep but that's
nothing - I do I do jack off before I
write cuz I'm like I need to relax and
then clear out my balls a boner
system but if you don't then they turned
into like a romantic novel you should
write before pages and then check off
and then there writes another four pages
well then your hands get sticky in the
keyboard wash your [ __ ] hands there's
Colvin okay but no point no but it's
already from your own body chances are
you get to four pages and you're like
well I could probably do five six seven
eight and then you didn't you wait and I
promise you guys no matter what the [ __ ]
you write
you'll hate it in a couple years anyway
so maybe true promise you so it's about
it's about just getting this one done
for your tastes right now and then later
on you'll be like oh yeah I see the
flaws I hate that one but
internet-famous was a good movie dude
thanks bro but I can't really watch it
but personally I can't really watch it
because I just I just see all the things
I don't like about it now and it just
you know did that happens that just
happens
were you a direct runner or just the
letter I wrote and I started it yeah but
you also feel like every now you evolve
so much past it so the point isn't
making the perfect thing is just getting
it done yeah it's not about hating on
the past I don't kind of burn my own
statues or whatever the [ __ ] getting it
under your belt it's getting on your
belt and then getting the next one going
yeah and then like you know and also
know your [ __ ] audience to like you
know I wrote the thinning which is not
for the [ __ ] like adults it's for a
young adult audience and like it has its
own little following and that's how we
got a sequel so those movies aren't
really like my personal thing I'm not
gonna like you at all go watch the game
together but but it's good for that
audience it's like one of those movies
get under your belt so you're saying you
made Logan Paul famous is what you're
saying
I made him I put him on the map nobody
knew who the [ __ ] he was so I pulled
that kid out of the [ __ ] mud Oh see
you're responsible for that I didn't
know I'm Guinea no but okay so then I
did this movie a funny story which was
more of like something that we wanted to
do that we earned because we yeah we
didn't sup to some big studio or some
[ __ ] it was like this is our movie house
really and you're in that movie and I
liked that movie that ones I'm like this
is pretty close so like what I really
really
like what I love right and then even
that Louie now I'm like I'm not gonna
watch it for a while I'm just gonna
[ __ ] table it so you got it you got a
fall in love with your new shake your
YouTube videos like you shouldn't like
when you look back on your first youtube
video you're like oh yeah
I don't think it was that that like not
made us finish the script though I think
was just like laziness a little bit
laziness I think it was a little bit of
perfectionism none of the profession
he's talking about mm-hmm I I think just
mostly laziness column a column B and
then just like trying to get it like
done in that short amount of time
because we've never done it I don't
think your first script Holland it's
horrible it was horrible I wrote it in a
car no I take it took no not virginity
this script writing that script took
probably nice I took eight days because
when when it's time to do something you
got to put everything else aside like
Bart saying you gotta just [ __ ] close
there's no reasoning another tab there's
no phones in the room there's no other
screens you're doing it or else your
thoughts
fine this is gonna be my writing coach
and then Sao Paulo and you guys as blogs
are two-week break you don't have to
just be 48 hours right yeah
48 hours you're 24 hours 24 hours I'm
giving you time to sleep first day for
our block brainstorm the logline of your
movie you have some irony and you know
why this movie's good take an hour lunch
another four hours
you beat sheet it you're done one one
day full solid outline next day three
four-hour blocks act 1 act 2 act 3
you're done that's that's two days you
sleep you have eight hours and that's it
and you stay focused don't go on your
phone or do anything else go and stick
to it and if you get stuck double or
nothing
I'm your buddy you two drops and 250
burpees it was 100 we settled on film so
don't worry we can go back don't worry
Jim if you get stuck you can call me up
now cuz I'm so [ __ ] good or whatever
it's just to bounce your [ __ ] off of me
and then get another perspective and
then I can help you break through work
that was the idea behind them
a group together so that they could like
be like oh no come on man we made a
group for everybody but they bully the
blind can lead the blind did your mom
know you Tuesday in the group trap you
guys go through the messages I'll really
[ __ ] out the automobile do this no I
think the first message is like you
already do burpees [ __ ] way and here's
all [ __ ] up it is right because I knew
I thought I was slacking way more than
everyone else especially after we
started the group chat and I was gonna
check in but then I was like let me just
leave it alone just in case everyone
else is [ __ ] up and like so we can be
like oh we never talked about it why
even bring it up but then I knew we're
gonna bring it up for content what I was
doing good but I was also I was like the
more positive one in the group I was
like come on guys it's now or never we
always like you what do you mean I was
like being super positive and then
they'll be like positivity doesn't write
a script
what doesn't you do and picture of you
on page 35 is what's gonna motivate them
it's not like nobody had on like I'm on
page 35 30 pages already yeah it's like
nobody had time during kovat bro well
that's how it happened is that like they
all we're gonna write a script during
the quarantine and then they didn't the
rights went to movies which is great I
wrote two and they're done they're both
done whoa there's a not [ __ ] gum
flappin here you know what the hot sauce
yeah yeah
so what wait I wasn't here for that -
what is the punishment under burpees
hundred rupees it's yeah it's um it's
hot I don't wanna hear from you loser no
no it's salsa from no from New York from
New York City so I'm spicy New York
salsa and then in New York City
hey from New York City and you guys are
luck because I ordered it
oh my god he got it done that's really
what the gloves are for so this is so
hey barn humming screen plays have you
written all if you only buy through farm
exactly these guys zero let me say
something my 10 pages are fire yeah oh
you like a camera what you've logged
about the thing on their blogs do what
you wanna do see right now yeah no no
Casey this is great
listen you made a bet you have to
[ __ ] fulfill the bed that we're not
gonna be able to film the rest of the
day that's the American Way that's
that's part of any leaves in it before
he says where I'm gonna shoot the rest
of the day we played with like Katy for
12 episodes I think we could do this
content without your tongue you're gonna
do all the rest articles without your
tongue how would you do at the end I saw
that to me that's pretty fair
oh yeah sorry further word in this video
up there wait for another [ __ ] [ __ ]
tease yeah what do you think
just as a man John's channel it'll be
like you guys are holding your breath in
those videos okay but we're not doing
the purpose don't do the purpose just so
we did have flash beam I'm more afraid
of the burpees than iron that so we do
have the flash part because Joe's gonna
be expired so I don't want you guys to
have like tummy aches or nothing keeps
itself fresh can you have that same
attitude about the bathrooms what let's
open the bathroom let's get some soap in
there please turn that TV web whites are
pretty dry yeah bro thanks right wipes
Oh God Maia I'm gonna pee first we still
never saw a sasquatch main that grenade
thing I don't know it is but then I felt
like you was gonna be expired I don't
want that tummy aches so I got it I got
it I got you guys fresh hot sauce what
is this one does it taste good no you
write your script wait for 10 all right
keep it going keep going school coach
I'll see you guys so as I discussed on a
previous vlog y'all know I made a bet
with the beam and all the JK folks here
that Casey he's not here in case you
guys won so we didn't finish our scripts
so we're gonna take a drop of what is
this dog flashbang it's flat we're
supposed to use flash man but I think
it's expired so I got you guys fresh
ones
this one's called Satan's blood no one
looks way worse than flashbang I make
the content good Gio
what's up Steve head so yeah so how do
you guys want to do it like do you want
me to Jude foolish 100 Gio wasn't here
you weren't here boots pretty crazy yeah
these guys were here
the Dean said he took a drop of the
other [ __ ] he almost puked or did you
puke no everything okay but doesn't
change the fact that I did cause it's
probably crazy yeah but what if it no
you try it first
let's begin drop how about everybody try
it yeah what you can do according
alright so there's a drop on each oh god
you guys have to lick it until the whole
thing disappear put backwards yeah
holy Shh just runs haha even though
that's a letter I put I literally put a
drop in just one no this is not no I put
I'll show you I put a drop and it just
runs all the way down to coax it don't
be a [ __ ] man Nadeem handy because I
get it are you thinking straight to the
throat or you on the ER your tongue
tastes to me like this bro just do it
does is not a drop tell your family how
much you love them real quick in that
camera which camera that camera right
there black box alright those would be
worse I think nervous or something sit
together yeah are you guys ready well
good like for Tammy I don't want to make
it worse I'm good hi I'm sorry I'm good
after no no no I won't take it in toll
but I'll be I'll be good alright alright
I think I'll call is gonna help this hey
who's coming three two one action
immediately we remember your chunker on
to now you're not delaghetto just
getting real in here how come he's
taking it like a man
yeah but spicy fresh ones oh [ __ ]
Timmy's the inspiration over there he's
meditating right
you dig deep bro titties my [ __ ] soul
needed mortal oh [ __ ] sorry but how are
you gonna film other videos is my
question I guess what are you guys
better right your cervix then this is
what you get my company place to begin
games the wind stupid prices getting
crazy in here steeple to that good job
Tim oh my goodness oh yeah this is my
wife everybody can even open his water
at all okay guys you drink you're gonna
have to throw out that better trash it's
getting worse what do you want like Rice
Krispies I know what you guys are
thinking right now I just want to say
squeeze
let's blame Bart you didn't write your
scripts yes you could have done it all
Bart did was made you face the
consequences of your actions
art was just being a good agent dad he's
been a good friend trying to help you
that we breathe but now you got all you
haters all this Bart making me do all
this crazy [ __ ]
oh he's being mean but no haters because
these guys need to taking responsibility
for their actions
you know oh good to hear [ __ ] mayor
dude
ready Dave do you money do that I think
I'd be like with you I'd be like
Medina's how did you do that that's
crazy
what is that is that bread okay well
rice krispy that's the closest to bread
we got is it helping Nick he's loving it
can tell absolutely love it
this is this good content I gotta say
I'm enjoying this video being and being
attacked so now we just need Casey did
what do you think all right you guys
missed a key party yeah Brian should
they subscribe to the Steve head check
definitely yeah I'll be doing double or
nothing that D oh yeah do you want a
balloon to spit up support and two more
weeks
no I quit all bet sounds like that's
working I don't think they want to be
writers anymore this is what what it
took I had to do it you know how much
hot sauce Blake Snyder's bottles so you
throw one up was awesome good job man
hot boys whatever we want
heads out yeah okay it's like when you
are hot
it's like your whole mouth gets tingly
yeah yeah in the flashbang
honest no
how's your vision oh it's like that huh
visions okay just ours you know it's
here an upside I get it yeah I bet the
tops off still be careful yeah that's
one of those very oily these are always
very oily
yeah
[Music]
[Music]